All right. For this sweets classic interview,
the topic of a Medicare for all or some system
that would get care to everybody regardless
of ability to pay was popularized. It was
really sort of mainstreamed by Bernie Sanders
in 2016, many of the 20, 20 Democratic candidates
are now talking about this. And we did an
x, uh, an interview with a really knowledgeable
expert on the issue, uh, back in 2012. Okay.
This is how far ahead of this thing we were
in 2012 isn't even early. All right. But from
the point of view of a show doing this stuff
in depth, we wa we're doing this, uh, 2012
and earlier and in 2012 I interviewed Dr Carol
Paris and uh, that's the topic and particularly
relevant today. Note the language that was
used in the interview with Carol Paris compared
to the language that we're using now. Different
language but still talking about very similar
ideas. Let's get right to it.
Dr Carol Paris is joining us. She's a psychiatrist
in private practice in Maryland, also a member
of Physicians for a National Health Program.
Dr Paris. It's great to talk to you. I think
a good place to start will be, uh, to get
your sense of why you think a single payer,
national health care program would be, would
be a better thing than we have now. But also
I'd be curious to hear why some of your other
colleagues, other doctors aren't unanimous
in that, in that idea. If it is, if it is
the beneficial as I believe you think it is.
Well, thank you for having me on the show.
Um, yes, I do think that it is beneficial
and there's lots of statistics we can talk
about or not, um, to support why it is beneficial
both for, um, physicians and most importantly,
um, for 95% of, um, the, uh, Americans in
terms of just economically advantageous to
them, not to mention giving them comprehensive
coverage. Um, but why do I, so I think it's,
it's beneficial both from an economic standpoint
and from a moral, ethical, um, you know, healthcare
is a human right perspective. But even if
you, you know, even if you don't approach
it from that perspective, just from an economics
standpoint, it is superior. Um, why do I think
other physicians, um, aren't on board with
it? Um, well actually, 59% of positions that
were surveyed back in 2008 and remember that's
even before the affordable care act met, you
know, 2009 legislation that said that they
thought that, uh, uh, national health program
would be superior and that was up 10% from
five years earlier. That was published in
the annals of internal medicine. And just
if you look at the numbers of membership in
Physicians for a National Health Program,
our membership increased by three or 4,000
physicians in 2009 simply because there was
so much more, um, awareness of the problems
with our healthcare system even though there
was not a great deal of, of public awareness
of single payer as a, an option.
So let's talk about that a little bit. I mean,
I think on this program we talk a lot from
the patient point of view, why a single payer
system would, would be better. But as, as
a practicing physician, I'm curious what your
thoughts would be about how would that allow
you to provide better care or would it, would
it affect, uh, how would it affect the income
of the average position? I mean, go into that
a little bit.
Oh, I'd be glad to. I got into this. As I
said, I joined P and h p in 2009 and that
was after I had spent 45 years with our state
med, the Maryland State Medical Society. And
I was very active in this state medical society
and I was quite proud of a piece of legislation
that I got, was instrumental in getting passed
that was designed to get the insurance companies
on one particular issue to play fair. And
um, when it was all said and done, when the
regulations were written, they were written
by the insurance companies and there no fine
for violating the law. And, and it was at
that point that I just said, you know, there's,
there is something wrong with insurance companies.
No matter what we do, they will find a work
around, they will find a way to get around
any legislation that you pass. And that's
when I got involved in, in Physicians for
a National Health Program and started looking
at putting a dollar sign on what that would
mean for me in my own practice. And one of
the things that I came across was an article
in health affairs that, um, suggests that
the average primary care physician, the cost
to the average primary care physician is 68,000.
So we're around $68,000 a year per physician
per year. Just as the cost of dealing with
multiple insurance companies.
Okay. So this takes into consideration, if
I understand the average primary care physician,
I don't know what numbers you're using, is
it a slate of about 2,500 patients that they
have a kind of on their roster?
I don't know what the number of patients is.
This was published in health affairs.
Okay. So, but the idea would be that the average
physician with an average patient load because
of both billing and timing put into working
with insurance companies would stand to save
$68,000 if that bureaucracy was eliminated.
That is correct. Okay. Now as far as, as far
as care is concerned, does it just follow
that simply by not having to deal with that
you're providing better care? Well, I think
usually you have people working in on the
billing side. So I don't know that that's
the argument. But how would translate to better
care?
Well, actually the people that I have working
on the billing side are medical, um, assistance.
They could actually be doing blood pressures
and weights and actual things that would be
good for my patients rather than answering
phones and chasing prior authorizations. So
from that perspective it would be good for
the patients. Plus if I don't, if I'm getting
a raise simply by not having to spend, have
so much overhead go into, I'm dealing with
multiple insurance companies, then I might
actually be able to see a couple fewer patients
a day and spend more time with the patients
that I'm actually seeing, which definitely
translates into better care. I think if you
ask the average patient what their feeling
is about the amount of time that their physician
spends with them, I don't think you're often
going to hear that, that patients feel like
their doctor spends as much time as he or
she need or at least from the patient's perspective,
um, that the patient feels is necessary. And
I don't think that's because doctors don't
like to spend time with patients. It's because
we're like hamsters in a cage. Unless we see
a volume of patients every day, we can't pay
the bills. We can't pay our staff and have
any money left over for an income.
So on the, on the last end of this, I guess
my question would be about as far as, and
this is probably a uh, an issue with that,
it has multiple influences, both the fear
of lawsuits but also what insurance companies
will and won't cover, which is that of necessary
or unnecessary tests that are often done.
We just did a piece a couple of weeks ago
about a number, I think it's 45 different
tests that a, a group of doctors came together
and said, you know, these are really overdone.
And if people did them less, you know, and
in specific more specific conditions, we would
actually eliminate a ton of spending at the
same time. A lot of the reason that those
tests are being done is because doctors both
need to cover themselves and know that if
they're not done in documented future procedures
may not be covered. So talk a little bit about
how the diagnoses and testing might change
with a single payer healthcare system.
Well, the argument is made the doctors do
so much of the testing because they're afraid
of being sued. Right? Right. And so when you
think about malpractice, um, and you look
at what, when you break a malpractice award
down, the majority of the money in any malpractice
award is for, is to cover the patient for
future medical care. Hmm. Well, guess what,
that away if we had a national health program,
because that's already assured. You get your
Medicare card the day you're born and you
lose it the day you die. So necessarily every
malpractice award is going to be significantly
reduced. If we had a national health program,
which then translates into, um, a smaller
premium for your malpractice insurance because
the pay outs are not what they used to be,
which again translates into more income for
doctors and fewer malpractice claims. Because
the majority of the reason that people pursue
a malpractice claim in the first place is
because they need to be assured of continued
care. And if they don't have to be assured
of continued care than if it's one of those
cases where it really wasn't malpractice.
But w but it's equivocal and the patient's
not is going to have expensive care for the
rest of their lives. That goes away with the
national health program.
Okay. I wish we had more time. We've been
speaking with Dr Carol Paris. She's a psychiatrist
in private practice in Maryland, also a member
of Physicians for a National Health Program.
Really great to speak to you and we'd love
to have you back again. 19 very much.